if a man does not love Solitude he will
not love freedom for it is only when he
is alone that he is really
free everyone takes the limits of his
own vision for the limits of the
world a pessimist is an optimist in full
possession of the
[Music]
facts politeness is the human nature
what warmth is to
wax truth is most beautiful
undraped in Action a great heart is the
chief qualification in work a great
head honor has not to be won it must
only not be
lost Talent hits a Target no one else
can hit genius hits a Target no one else
can
see Ordinary People merely think how
they shall spend their time a man of
talent uses
[Music]
it well one should use common words to
say uncommon
things hope is the confusion of the
desire for a thing with its
probability to overcome difficulties is
to experience the full Delight of
existence willpower is to the mind like
a strong blind man who carries on his
shoulders a lame man who can
see to feel Envy is human to savor
shoden Freud is
[Music]
devilish how shall a man be proud when
his conception is a crime his birth a
penalty his life a labor and his death a
necessity each day is a little life
nature shows that with the growth of
intelligence comes increased capacity
for
[Music]
pain sleep is the interest we have to
pay on the capital which is called in at
death if you want to know your true
opinion of someone watch the effect
produced in You by the first sight of a
letter from
him
almost all of our sorrows spring from
our relations with other
[Music]
people we forfeit three quarters of
ourselves in order to be like other
[Music]
people every nation ridicules other
nations and all are
right it is difficult to find happiness
within oneself but it is impossible to
find it anywhere
else the greatest of folies is to
sacrifice health for any other kind of
Happiness a man can be himself only so
long as he is
alone it is a clear gain to sacrifice
pleasure in order to avoid
pain
the closing years of life are like the
end of a masquerade party when the masks
are
dropped a sense of humor is the only
Divine quality of
man happiness consists in frequent
repetition of
pleasure wealth is like seawater the
more we drink the thirstier we become
the same is true of
Fame the two enemies of human happiness
are pain and
boredom the safest way of not being
miserable is not to expect to be
[Music]
happy money is human happiness in the
abstract life is a constant process of
dying we seldom think of what we have
but always of what we
[Music]
lack every possession and every
happiness is but lent by chance for an
uncertain time and may therefore be
demanded back the next
[Music]
hour all truth passes through three
stages first it is
ridiculed second it is violently imposed
third it is accepted as being
[Music]
self-evident in our monogamous part of
the world to marry means to have one's
rights and to double one's
duties there is no doubt that life is
given to us not to be enjoyed but to be
overcome to be got
over
the person who writes for fools is
always sure of a large
audience what people commonly call fate
is mostly their own
stupidity no one writes anything worth
writing unless he writes it entirely for
the sake of the
subject Wicked thoughts and worthless
efforts gradually set their mark on the
face especially the
[Music]
eyes mostly it is loss which teaches us
about the worth of
things it is only at the first encounter
that a face makes its full impression on
us the word of man is the most durable
of all
material
it's the ni cities that make the
difference fate gives us the hand and we
play the
cards a poet or philosopher should have
no fault to find with his age if it only
permits him to do his work undisturbed
in his own
Corner if we were not all so interested
in ourselves life would be so
uninteresting that none of us will be
able to endure
it to be alone is the fate of all great
minds a fate deplored at times but still
always chosen as the less Grievous of
two
evils boredom is just the reverse side
of Fascination both depend on being
outside rather than inside a situation
and one leads to the
other
great men are like eagles they build
their nest on some lofty
Solitude the bad thing about all
religions is that instead of being able
to confess their allegorical nature they
have to conceal
it no rose without a thorn but many a
thorn without a
[Music]
rose the difficulty is to try to teach
the multitude that something can be true
and untrue at the same
[Music]
time conscience accompanies Every Act
with a comment you should act
differently although its true sense is
you could be other than you
[Music]
are
religion is the Masterpiece of the art
of animal training for it trains people
as to how they shall
think men are the Devils of the earth
and the animals are the tormented
[Music]
Souls after your death you will be what
you were before your
birth life swings like a pendulum
backward and forward between pain and
[Music]
boredom the more intelligent a man is
the less mysterious existence seems to
him the only Freedom that exists is of a
metaphysical character in the physical
world freedom is an
[Music]
impossibility hatred hatred is an affair
of the heart contempt that of the
[Music]
head it is with Trifles and when he is
off guard that a man best Reveals His
[Music]
character will minus intellect
constitutes
[Music]
vulgarity men are by Nature merely
indifferent to one another but women are
by Nature your
[Music]
enemies